[Music]
foreign
[Music]
president of Google Cloud International
and head of Google Island Adair Fox
Martin
[Music]
good morning
Google Cloud next I'm delighted to have
all of you here with us today and to the
tens of thousands joining us virtually
from across the region thank you so much
for tuning in and for those of you here
in Munich it's been three years three
whole years since we've had the chance
to connect face-to-face At a next event
and we have a lot to catch up on
I'd like to take a moment if I could to
thank all of our partners who've helped
to make this event possible
special thanks to our loomery sponsors
Accenture atos
c3ai and Deloitte
indeed Google Cloud could not do what we
do for our customers without the
continuing and ongoing support of our
partners
and I can't actually think of a more
fitting location to bring us all back
together I had the pleasure of living
here in Germany for nearly five years
and it's truly synonymous with
technology as a case in point right here
in Munich it's home to the largest
Technology Museum in the world
but it isn't called that Technology
Museum it's simply called the German
Museum
technology is already applied
and today we'll be looking at the
transformative power of cloud technology
and how it can help drive your
organization's transformation forward
this is what today is all about
your transformation
and how Google helps
and from the main stage and in our
breakout sessions you'll hear directly
from our customers about both the value
and the experience they are driving via
their transformation with Google Cloud
you'll hear how they're solving some of
the most critical business problems and
also taking on some of the world's most
formidable challenges today
tomorrow
and long into the future
so let's get started to set the stage
let's connect with our very first
customers
in the past few years Renault Alliance
and Seb have both aggressively been
pursuing transformation strategies
and for both organizations Cloud
technology sits at the very core of
their transformations
to share more about this bold course of
action please join me in welcoming two
leaders Renault alliance's vice
president of I.T Services Stefan vanuk
and Petra uland head of Tech and the
group executive committee member from
Seb please join me and welcome to the
stage
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
to have you so thank you so much for
being with us maybe we start off by
helping the audience here to understand
a little bit about the vision for
transformation that you have in your
company Stefan let's start with you on
the Renault story okay thank you renew
groups here you has a strategic Vision
in fact to Pivot from a company with 124
years of history in making vehicle to a
tech company we want to move from a car
manufacturer to a provider of Mobility
Services
when we say transformation we mean
transformation across all area of the
business
first a new approach to our product when
a group is completely changing what is
delivered to its customer from offering
just vehicle we are moving to offering
Mobility Services our vision is that 20
of our Revenue will come from Services
by 20 to 30. this means a new approach
to product development to deliver
Electrify connected and software defined
vehicle by 2025.
second we are changing the company
business operating model all operations
will be cloud-based data-driven and EI
enabled we need to gain in agility and
stability improve security and at the
same time continuously provide new
Services the cloud delivers the best
platform for us to drive these
opportunities oh we I definitely agree
about Cloud being the best platform for
you what about you and Petra tell us a
little bit about seb's Ambitions and
vision to transform yeah SCB was formed
165 years ago so this will definitely
not be our first transformation we are a
wholesale bank but we're also one of the
largest IIT organization in the nordics
banking day is about itun data that's
where we meet our customers expectations
with new Innovative services and we
believe traditional banks with our key
asset in people and funds can use the
cloud in very powerful ways to be the
best banks of tomorrow
digital transformation is critical to
our ability to succeed with these
business goals and from a technology
standpoint we have a set Vision to be
Cloud native by 2030.
having said that it's important for us
to acknowledge that we must execute both
the new and The Proven technologies that
we operate at the same time feet on the
ground head in the cloud is one of our
mantras so we start with selected
Business Review use cases in areas like
data and analytics stability of this
balance
additional technology part is like
Google Cloud enable us to develop and
manage a digital and data security and
cyber defense with the confidence and
this has never been as important as in
the current geopolitical and economic
context and in our view doing this in
the cloud is the only way forward yeah
so it seems that business and digital
transformation are synonymous at Sev
um Stephen how does Google support
renault's Ambitions in that regard
well Google is a critical part of our
digital transformation we are working on
the end-to-end process from a car design
to its launch through the manufacturing
quality check Supply Chain management
and delivery to the dealers the car
usage will be then monitor analyze using
our care data platform for a better
understanding of our customers
honey was also connected over 30
manufacturing plant and the associated
supply chain to the Google Cloud
platform in order to collect data we are
switching to data-driven manufacturing
and supply chain models the data
collection using AI enables us to
optimize our energy consumption and
improve efficiency through predictive
maintenance this is also support our
sustainability program which is a huge
part of our transformation objective we
are also addressing the new b2c channel
by connecting cars to gcp using the
unique analytic capability of the
platform it is an opportunity for us to
better know our user and customer we can
offer them the best possible experience
customized feature and new services and
provide pay-as-you-go Mobility Services
any company and undergoing a shift of
these magnitudes are to stress the
security of the platform they are
choosing We Trust Google secure
infrastructure and are confident that
you will also have greater solution for
us to comply with the French digital
Serenity requirement as an example our
first strategy was multi-cloud then we
switched to a gcp first
Beyond trust or a new group choose
Google as a partner for multiple reasons
Google cloud is offering the best value
for money Google cloud is offering true
Cloud flexibility and ability to respond
to short and long-term challenges uh and
Cloud the Google cloud data is the best
value proposal on today's market and
then of course the Google teams are very
skilled and very supportive to any of
our challenge oh thank you so much
Stefan for some of your kind remarks
there
um Petra how are you at SCB working with
Google on the other digital
transformation efforts that you have in
the company yeah when we started our
journey to become Cloud native we
evaluated many options and why we're
setting on a multi-cloud strategy Google
cloud has supplied all the functionality
we've needed so far but more than that
their true partnership in helping us
solve challenging problems through an
integrated approach of collaboration
technology and training has really been
an asset for us
and in a highly regulated industry
building trust is a foundation for
personalized Services it's enabled by
technology for security know your
customer and compliance
and with our new data platform we'll be
able to use current and historical data
in a more intelligent way and speed up
the creation of new innovative solutions
for our customers
being able to automate more and spend
less time managing infrastructure allow
us to focus on developing those new
Solutions like embedded Banking and
self-service digital banking
sap is actively supporting sustainable
transition and that is by offering
advisory Services Innovative and
sustainable financing and investment
products and we support our customers in
their transitions
to the Paris agreement for climate
change
so our role is very much to enable
companies and individuals to make
choices that contribute to sustainable
Society
so with our updated sustainability
strategy we raise our ambition level
further and take the next step in
accelerating the sustainability
transition and Google's track record and
ambition and credibility is
inspirational
our experience of working with Google is
that Google combines both the stability
reliability and responsibility of a
major Enterprise
and also the speed Innovation and
flexibility of a startup thank you for
that and thank you to both of you for
taking the time to come today and share
your insights with this I think the
stories that you've shared present a
great backdrop for some of the
discussions that will come today and
certainly at Google Cloud we look
forward to continuing our partnership
with you ladies and gentlemen can you
please join me in a big thanks for
Stefan and Petra thank you thanks
thanks
now as Stefan and Petra shared working
with Google is more than about achieving
consistency and convenience
it's about helping organizations right
across Emir on their journey of
sustainable change
and to provide some additional context
about transformation and how it's so
underpinned by Cloud technology
I'd like to hand it over now to our CEO
of Google Cloud Thomas Korean
thank you again
I'd also like to extend a very warm
welcome to our customers and partners
we're really delighted to have you all
with us
to Echo Adair across Europe Middle East
and Africa now more than ever
cloud is essential for digital
transformation
a lot of cloud work to date has been
focused solely on cost optimization
reducing costs by moving technology to
the cloud using collaboration tools and
being more efficient
but as we look forward
companies and customers want more than
just cost optimization they also want
value creation
cloud has to deliver more value and more
Innovation to organizations
from understanding your customers better
helping you make your supply chain more
resilient bringing people together to
improve not just their productivity but
their creativity
and creating seamless interactions
across your entire value chain
we're committed at Google Cloud through
the digital transformation of all
businesses across Europe Middle East and
Africa and the continued investments in
Cloud on Europe's terms to support
sovereignty security and sustainability
it's inspiring to see how organizations
across the region are leading the way in
this new era
Vodafone for instance has migrated to
Google Cloud to drive breakthroughs in
artificial intelligence and machine
learning that have helped it improve
Customer Loyalty through personalized
offers and NPS predictions
Swiss International Airlines is using
Google Cloud to optimize plane rotation
to better align with booking demand
helping them better accommodate
customers and save Millions
and HSBC has launched more than 250 live
Services
across its organization to support the
experience of over 40 million customers
around the world
what sets these organizations apart
and what you will hear from many of our
customers today
is that they have systematically
embraced Cloud as the foundation for
their digital transformation
to share more about this I'll hand
things back to you there
thank you again for having me and I hope
you all enjoy the rest of Google Cloud
next
thanks so much Thomas
the transformation era of cloud is
marked by a completely different kind of
conversation
the questions from our customers are no
longer just about convenience and
efficiency
they are about the very core of their
businesses
and organizations are asking five key
questions
how do we become the best at
understanding and using data
how do we ensure we have the best
technology infrastructure
how do we know that our data our systems
and our users are secure
how do we create the best workplace for
our people
and how do we collectively create
a more sustainable future
now last year we introduced those
questions on behalf of our customer
today our customers are going to share
how they've answered them
with the help of Google Cloud
so for the first two questions please
join me in welcoming Garrett casmeyer VP
and general manager of data and
analytics right here at Google Cloud
Garrett
all right thank you there so how does an
organization actually become the best at
understanding and using their data you
know it turns out data is at the heart
of digital Innovation and it's really
the key to unlocking AI
the challenge is though that today data
is generated at far greater rates
and the clue is that it's being trapped
in the new data silos of different
formats of Point Solutions and of closed
clouds
but when data is unlocked it can really
improve everything it can make Supply
chains smarter it can help you to build
contextualized customer applications and
it can truly improve everybody I'm
talking about all your customers I'm
talking about all your employees and I'm
talking about all your partners
Google is a leader in the analysis of
structured and unstructured data and we
are unifying the data ecosystem for you
creating the most open data cloud
and this includes actually all of your
data in all of your formats from all
sources from any clouds and collectively
it's about enabling all styles of
analysis so here is coming you know one
big announcement exactly in that Spirit
today we announced the support of
unstructured data in bigquery with that
you can combine your unstructured data
with your structure data from your
operational databases and SAS
applications
and if that basically big Fury becomes
the point for which you cannot connect
all of this data with our machine
learning platform all through this
simple and familiar SQL interface of
bigquery
a very interesting statistic is that 90
of our customers they are analyzing data
also from other clouds
now with bigquery Omni you can access
data and Azure and in AWS but without
even moving that data that makes it
simple and it saves you egress fees
now we brought all of this data together
right so what comes next well you want a
UNIF you want to unify query that in a
simple way
well today we're going to announce the
integration of spark into big queries
open query engine and with that you get
a single interface for both SQL and
Apache spark right in bigquery
and I can imagine what most of you are
thinking right now if you're onto data
like I am so let's talk about it let's
talk about data Lakes for a second
big very dust support key file formats
for which you can build data lakes and
lake houses through the announcement
that we made recently called Big Lake
and today we are announcing the support
of Apache Iceberg and the upcoming
support of the popular firm is hoodie
and Delta
now after we connected all of this data
together well that's connected to all of
you let's connect all of this data to
people and the first stop is business
intelligence
in the business intelligence base let's
be honest we actually have two sets of
data on the one side there is
centralized highly governed and
well-managed data it's used for
standardized Reapers and dashboards and
on the other side well we have that not
so much official data it's often
distributed and it's many times used for
self-service dashboarding right
Google has products for both of these
worlds first we have looker it is the
leading product for governed data access
it has strong business semantics and
it's really the foundation for data
driven application building
and we have Google cloud data Studio
it's one of the most popular tools for
self-service data visualizations and
discovery
if you combine them together today they
have more than 10 million users a month
and today we announced that we are
unifying these two products into a
single offering called looker and lucra
studio and with that actually we're
going to unify self-service bi with
trusted data
we are also announcing lucra Studio Pro
Luca Studio Pro is an enhancement of
that with additional support and
management capabilities and well you
know with
obviously you know you would think no
this is a Google only story but I talked
about being committed to an open data
Cloud right so we are also working with
all of the leading bi vendors we are
already working with Tableau but today
we are announcing the briefly of looker
support for Microsoft power bi
so
let's move on from bi to AI
last year we have announced vertex AI
our machine learning platform and that
requires 80 percent less code than other
comparable platforms to Drain Machine
learning models but the reality is that
today most of the data is actually video
data and it has been really really hard
to get meaningful insights out of video
streams so today I'm very excited to
announce vertex AI Vision it is an
end-to-end fully managed development
platform for vision AI applications it
allows you to easily ingest analyze and
store video stream data and it comes
with pre-drained machine learning models
for common actions and it takes down
development times from Days down to
minutes now this is time to value
an open data Cloud must also enable a
connected ecosystem from SAS
applications to all of the technology
Partners out there many here in the
audience I assume and our data cloud
makes it much much simpler to access
data from all of these SAS applications
out I'm talking about servicenow workday
sap Adobe and many more
with sap actually we have created
predefined integration points you have
models in bigquery and out of the box
reports and in the latest version of it
it just takes seven minutes to get
deployed
One customer who is taking advantage of
that today is called for and they have
reduced both their operating expenses
and their energy consumption by moving
their data Centric sap architect
architecture to the cloud and now with
our data technology they are getting
insights and take actions in real time
on both Supply Chain management and
inventory Logistics
we also have 800 technology Partners who
are building their products on top of
Google Cloud today and 17 of the most
influential data companies in the cloud
have joined us in the data Cloud
Alliance program it is a program with
the commitment to Open Standards and
interoperability
we also expanded our Partnerships with
calibra palantir elastic mongodb
servicenow and many more
because the bottom line of all of this
is
you need an open data cloud
and with all of these announcements
today we are taking a major step forward
in making this a reality for all of you
now obviously I can talk about data with
you the entire day but we have to move
on to the second question and talk about
how do you get the best possible
infrastructure
and for us you know for me being an
engineer myself great infrastructure
means that you can innovate and build
really really quickly the challenge is
though that yesterday's infrastructure
slows down development it makes
innovating really really hard and the
reason is quite simple
it's complexity it's tough to build
quickly you know when you have to select
from thousands of options when you have
to stitch together infrastructure all
the time and at the same point in time
think about you know the poor developer
you know managing costs and keeping
applications safe
the good news is though there is a
better way tomorrow's Cloud creates
Simplicity through what we call goals
and paths now golden paths are
prescriptive architectures and an
opinionated development model and the
point is that they reduce complexity
right from the IDE when you deployed
fruit production and here is a fantastic
example of a golden path today we are
launching software delivery shield and
that is a fully managed end-to-end
software supply chain security model
right from your source code into
deployment it has four key components
first a cloud workstation to develop
second can assured open source software
service that we are validating and
securing third Cloud build our
continuous integration service and gke
our manage our Security Management
dashboard all coming together in
software delivery Shield
another great example of golden paths is
our workload optimized infrastructure
that we are building in Google right
from the Silicon app and I'm going to
talk about three quick examples here and
we start obviously with the most
important one AI optimized
infrastructure Google has developed a
tensor processing units or the tpus and
the point was we wanted to massively
increase Hardware performance for AI
right
today we are announcing the general
availability of TPU version 4. they're
even faster and they're more effective
and the whole point of TPU version 4 is
that you can run really large machine
learning models in your companies for
your next breakthrough innovation
we are also super pleased and psyched to
announce the deeper integration with
Nvidia together with Nvidia we are
committed to using Ai workloads and
running AI workloads on their latest
technology that ranges from gpus to
managed machine learning services in
combination with Google AI models and a
great example of that is our joint
commitment to open source AI not only to
bring the ecosystem together but
actually to help all of you to prevent
platform and model login
the next stop is our Cloud first
workloads you know I was talking about
developers and 50 you know of developers
are actually using containers today and
Google contributed a very important
format in the container space called
kubernetes right Google kubernetes
engine is a fully managed service that
is already a big deal but a bigger point
is it scales to unprecedented levels pts
it's their norovich and geophysics
Company they have tripled their
deployment size with us
and they scaled up to
get this 21 petaflops does any of you
know what that means 21 petaflops that
means that pgs is now in the top 25 list
of the world supercomputers
just for the powers of kubernetes and
gke
to run kubernetes in different
environments we are providing enters and
anthos basically allows you to run
kubernetes in multi-cloud settings on
premise or on the edge and today we are
announcing a set of enhancements to make
multi-cluster management much simpler by
just deploying a single configuration
file to hundreds of clusters in
different environments
so we also want to stay ahead help you
stay ahead of emerging Technologies and
we are working with web free companies
the Pioneers in that space and they are
using our workload optimized
infrastructure for workloads such as
blockchain for instance and today we are
announcing that coinbase has selected us
as their Premier cloud provider and
partnering with us to enable the web
free community
so these golden paths they are really
our approach to give you the best
technology infrastructure and to talk
about the impact of that to their
business I would like to turn it to our
great partners and customers from the
Deutsche Bank team let's roll the video
[Applause]
if you don't have Financial stability
and you don't know that you can take
care of your dear ones your happiness is
impacted Deutsche Bank is leading German
and European bank that is transforming
the industry we are on a journey with
Google Cloud to redefine banking we are
building the foundations and the
infrastructure for a compliance secure
experience we're also enabling all of
our clients to really now leverage that
to better their life
what really excites me is the huge
transformation that we are driving at
the bank we're creating modern solutions
and New Opportunities Deutsche bank's
Frontier app is a cash flow and invoice
management platform for our clients it
allows them to in real time share their
invoices with their customers collect
payments from them automatically send
them reminders overall decrease in time
to capture a mandate and accept a
payment we brought that down from weeks
to days with 80 percent in sales
efficiencies one of the biggest benefits
of developing this app on Google cloud
is most of the services we needed
purchase out of the box so my team could
really focus on building the business
features we are able to connect to our
clients ecosystems becoming a part of
their entire business value chain and
Beyond the traditional boundaries of
banking
some of the key benefits for partnering
with Google cloud is speed security and
scalability by having data in one place
you can apply analytics you can build
machine learning Solutions the
partnership with Google Cloud allows us
from an innovation point of view work
directly with Google and Engineers
sometimes on products and services that
are not available in the market already
Google cloud is really at the heart of
our transformation that our great team
has and are able to implement it
efficiently
purely and at the right velocity the sky
is the limit
so I wanna I wanna end with this
when companies are empowered with an
intelligent simple and open data Cloud
the sky is indeed the limit and with
that I would like to hand it back to
Adair
[Music]
great job thanks so much
thanks so much Garrett so having the
power of an open data cloud and an open
infrastructure Cloud to drive your
transformation isn't meaningful unless
you can operate in a trusted environment
and this takes us to our third customer
question
how do we know our data our systems and
our users are secure
cyber security is naturally a top of
Mind concern for csos and it's
increasingly top of Mind in the c-suite
and in the boardroom
and on one hand csos need to defend
against increasingly sophisticated
threats and actors
but on the other hand they're faced with
an unprecedented shortage of cyber
Security Professionals
so how do we reconcile this
with our solution we are championing a
future of invisible security
in this approach security is engineered
in
operations are simplified and we pursue
a shared fate together
our commitment to you is twofold
first we work to keep you secure from
cyber attacks and to do this we utilize
the expertise that we've developed from
securing our own Google business and our
own billions of users
second we help you to quickly and
effectively identify and resolve cyber
threats
so what does this look like in action
using our new Chronicle Security
operation Suite Morgan sindel which is a
UK construction and regeneration company
ingests analyzes and retains all of its
security information eliminating what
was the typical trade-off between cost
and security blind spots
vertiv a leading provider of equipment
and services for data centers is now
analyzing more than 20 times more
security data and responding to three
times more security events
with exactly the same resources
security queries that used to take hours
now take seconds
our investment in your security is only
growing
we've recently completed our acquisition
of mandiant a leader in Dynamic cyber
defense
mandiant is known for being the best in
threat intelligence and an incident
response
Google cloud is the best at data and
Analytics
now that we're together we have the
latest threat intelligence from the
front lines and we can deliver this
automatically through SAS products
backed by the leading managed offerings
and Consulting Services of mandiant
jointly we can deliver on our shared
mission
of a more secure world
we understand
that to fully Embrace transformation in
the cloud
you not only need security
you also need Trust
you need confidence and peace of mind
that when you deploy the latest
Innovations
you can meet your unique requirements
for control
transparency and sovereignty
whether that's driven by your regulator
by geopolitical considerations or indeed
by the government and its policy
at Google Cloud we take a digital
sovereignty seriously
customers Partners policy makers and
governments have surfaced three
requirements in three very specific
areas
the first is data sovereignty which is
keeping control over encryption and
access to your data
the second is operational sovereignty
this is keeping visibility and control
over the provider operations
and the third is software sovereignty
this is running workloads without a
dependence on a provider software
to address these requirements we
launched our initiative Cloud on
Europe's terms in September of 2021.
to achieve data sovereignty we offer a
unique external encryption capabilities
allowing you to store and manage your
encryption keys outside of Google
Cloud's infrastructure and deny Google
access for any reason
to support data residency requirements
we continue to launch Cloud regions in
emir
just recently we launched new regions in
Qatar the Kingdom of Saudi Arabia and
Greece adding to our 16 Cloud regions
here in emir
and today I'm really excited to announce
new Cloud regions for four more
countries for Austria for Norway for
Sweden and South Africa
to support operational sovereignty we
offer an exceptionally strong set of
trusted Partnerships for stringent local
supervision
and to support software sovereignty
needs we offer hosted Cloud Solutions
now these Solutions are built on open
source Foundation embracing open apis
and services to enable interoperability
and most importantly survivability
they can run on the customer premises
they can run on Partner premises and
they meet the strict needs for
disconnected operations
our unique relationship with t-systems
in Germany here demonstrates how we
deliver both the full benefit of the
public cloud and confidence in
compliance with German regulations
and to discuss this I'd really like to
welcome on stage adal alcia CEO of two
systems please join me in welcome Nadal
hello dear
great to have you here Adele thank you
thank you so much so t-systems uh was
Google's Cloud's first digital
sovereignty partner in Europe and as you
know since then we've partnered in
France in Spain and in Italy and
probably more to come but it started
with you yes
um why do you think this partnership
model is so important not just for
Germany but in Europe and Beyond well
there first of all thank you for having
me it's great to be in a room full of
people again
um you know sovereignty has been a topic
for
um a period of time this is not a new
topic right
um it's driven by multiple factors
um geopolitical tensions is driving it
the bifurcation of the world between
East and West the fear of being
dependent on somebody and not being able
to move is another the war in Europe
that we didn't expect is fueling even
more this sovereignty sentiment
um and at the core of it as I said this
fear of dependency but also fear of not
complying with regulatory environments
and you talked about data data is a big
deal here right how do I control my data
how do I make sure I know exactly who is
touching it where is it Etc
and um we've seen this opportunity
develop over multiple years
um and we found this opening where we
worked jointly with you to develop the
engineering solution
um and um you know I'm super excited
about that because it is a unique way of
providing a hyperscaler solution with
the Sovereign controls that allows
company digitized allows them to use the
best of the cloud without losing their
sovereignty and their worries about
controls all right and I think you know
there's an element of trust here and I
think you know both of us appreciate
it's so easy to lose trust and so so
hard to win yes and when we look at
organizations that want to start or
accelerate their journey of digital
sovereignty as part of their
transformation narrative there's a lot
of questions and a lot of options to
navigate
what would your advice to be to this
audience about getting started well look
the first thing is
um this solution that we're talking
about is real
it's available we are launching it in
phases of course we introduce the
consolving controls in every quarter
we have now multiple customers that are
going live that are using this so it's
no longer a theoretical debate or
theoretical discussion so my advices go
for it right take advantage of it
um and I believe The Regulators in
Europe are going to put more and more
focus on this area they're already
asking and looking at legislations that
would require of course first the the
the mission critical infrastructures to
comply with certain security
requirements
that is going to be put into law and it
will extend beyond the mission critical
infrastructures they're encouraging the
companies to assess their environments
they're encouraging the companies to
move forward implementing the Solutions
in order to address this vulnerabilities
if you will so my advice is give us a
call and either Google or these systems
and we would be delighted to help you
think through it
so as our companies perform a risk
assessment you know often looking at
what The Regulators have suggested I
think there's a very strong sense that
the time to act as now as you said this
solution is available and that's because
of the upside that is significant so if
I asked you about that upside what would
excite you most about it look there's a
lot of things that I'm I'm super excited
about I'm excited first of all about
this
engineering solution that addresses
European concern
this is a unique solution
um it doesn't compromise in terms of
access to the hyperscaler stacks and all
of the exciting technology that you just
learned so I'm excited about bringing it
to the market and and showcasing it and
bringing customers on it I'm excited
about onboarding our clients
you know we're we're learning as we as
we bring every client on board and and
that makes us stronger that makes us
um revisit our road maps and decide what
to prioritize
um and villain I'm excited about our
co-innovations lab right I mean it is a
big investment in Munich uh where we
would we are building our teams bring
them together where the customers
actually can come and spend weeks
working with the teams and moving their
applications into the Sovereign cloud
all right well listen Adele thank you
for an incredible partnership thank you
for highlighting some very important
issues for us ladies and Gentlemen
please join me in thanking the CEO of
t-systems Adele thank you so much
so we are committed to making
Partnerships like the one we've just
discussed with the Dell available
wherever they're needed by local
legislation
they're part of our commitment to
deliver the most secure
most trusted Cloud to our customers here
in this region
we want to help you transform in full
confidence that your data your systems
and your users are secure
and compliant
now when we think about transformation
it's impossible without people
and we have to ensure that our people
are able to work together and they are
empowered to drive the change
over the past three years we
collectively have experienced nothing
less than an upheaval in our workplace
remote and office work have Blended and
combined into a hybrid workplace and
accommodating this with the right
collaboration and productivity tools has
become absolutely Paramount
so let's look at this question
how do we create the best hybrid
workplace for our people
Google workspace was built to answer
that question
workspace helps people communicate and
collaborate to get things done
regardless of where they work or how
they actually want to work
it is the world's most popular set of
productivity tools with over 3 billion
users across 8 million companies and we
absolutely continue to deliver
Innovation with more than 300 new
features delivered in the past year
alone
workspace is secure by Design leveraging
Google's industry leading zero trust
architecture
but how does that show up as value for
our customers
first let's look at just eat
they run Google workspace to keep their
staff connected and communicating
regardless of where they are
and when the lockdown hit they were able
to launch a campaign literally within
weeks to provide workers in the UK's
National Health Service discounted meals
for themselves and for their families
revolut a fintech also out of the UK
uses Google workspace for its teams to
collaborate across 26 regions and
deliver new banking products at speed
and right here in Germany zalando uses
Google workspace for communication
across its rapidly expanding operations
so you can see the momentum very clearly
in new rapidly growing businesses
according to Forbes 96
of companies in their 2021 next billion
dollar startups list are Google
workspace customers
and I think it's really important for
established traditional businesses to
take note because in a study of
University students
75 percent felt Google workspace offered
a more advanced seamless way for teams
to work together
what's more this preference actually
informs their choice of future employer
47 said Google workspace would make a
job offer a job offer at a future
workplace much more appealing
so Google workspace is by far more than
the sum of its parts and its
capabilities
it has been designed from the ground up
to help organizations thrive in a world
of hybrid work
more than any other set of tools Google
workspace helps create the ultimate
workplace
for today and I also think for the
future
now in our final segment today we move
from the future of the workplace
to the future of our planet
many of you here will recall the
intensity of the Heat this summer
breaking records triggering droughts and
even threatening food security for many
there's no doubt that climate change is
upon us
and today's Final question is one that
should always be top of the line
how do we collectively create a more
sustainable future
sustainability isn't a nice to have
it's an imperative
in good Economic Times and in bad it has
to stand at the top of an organization's
priorities
but interestingly we have found that you
can have your cake and eat it too
and what I mean by this is that you can
become more operationally efficient and
more innovative
by becoming more sustainable
the secret
is smarter data
to discuss this further let's welcome on
stage Stephanie Neo Neo man the VP of
I.T sourcing and infrastructure at
Lufthansa group and Neil cuz who's the
CEO of a Google Cloud partner geotab
please welcome Neil and Stephanie
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome thank you so much so thank you
Mo both for joining us different
companies but both in the Travel and
Transport sector so let's begin our
discussion by just asking to what extent
you agree in your industry that
sustainability is a data problem and
Neil will will start with you thanks
Adair and good morning to this really
impressive audience here today
um let me start by saying that
sustainability is at the core of
geotab's purpose we are global leaders
in iot and connected Vehicles supporting
over 40 000 customers many Fortune 500
companies in over 150 countries
the Data Insights That We Gather from
three million connected vehicles and
around 100 000 data points processed a
second ensures that we have the data
intelligence to support customers on
their sustainability Journey but here's
the real truth about commercial fleets a
large percentage of commercial vehicles
cannot yet be electrified
so with that being the case what can
organizations do to be more sustainable
the answer to that challenges as you
said data first you use the Data
Insights to make your non-electric
fleets more efficient reducing their
carbon footprint you do this by adding
sensors to the vehicles optimizing the
road routes optimizing the types of
vehicles used for a particular job
lowering the fuel consumption and idling
and managing inefficient driver Behavior
second we're seeing that with our Data
Insights vehicle electrification
projects often fail
by applying Data Insights you can make
the best decisions for electrification
using the data to understand the usage
patterns such as optimizing for range
where infrastructure is readily
available where and when Vehicles can be
charged using the insights from data you
can decide how much and what part of
your fleets can be electrified for
maximum benefits so to summarize yes
data intelligence must be at the core of
your sustainability transition in our
industry if you're going to move quickly
enough all right and what about
Lufthansa Stephanie how does it
contribute to sustainability from a data
perspective in the aviation industry
to make Aviation more sustainable is
really a huge challenge you can imagine
so however at Lufthansa group we have
set ourselves very ambitious climate
goals and will become a carbon neutral
Company by 2050. on the way towards that
Target we will halve the 2019 net
emissions by 2030 already so as the
first Airline group in Europe we are
proud that our clear emission reduction
path is officially in line with the
Paris climate agreement so quite an
ambition here for the aviation industry
a truly hard it is to decarbonize and
this challenge will be managed with
three levers mainly
the new aircraft which is currently the
main contributor to Safe emissions the
deployment of sustainable aviation fuel
and operational efficiency on top and of
course that is a very much data-driven
exercise so at Lufthansa we have used
Google Cloud to create a new cloud-based
operations decision support Suite
meaning the first Lufthansa subsidiary
to use this is Swiss first they pulled
in multiple sources of data regarding
their planes their Crews passengers and
schedules and then they applied AI tools
on top so they are now able to optimize
operational decisions with just sub
seconds response so let's look at just
one feature in that platform it's about
rotating planes within a short time that
feature alone has reduced fuel
consumption and does co2 emissions for
us so it's very clear to see the impact
on sustainability objectives
but for orgs that are transforming does
sustainability go hand in hand with
other desired business outcomes it might
be things like cost cutting maybe
operational efficiency or reimagining
the the customer experience I mean
Stephanie seeing there's probably a
number of us used your services to maybe
arrive in Munich today let's start with
you on this one
we've clearly seen this with the project
I just described the operations decision
support Suite so yes we are able to
reuse emissions but within the same time
and within the very same projects the
optimization we have saved money as well
yeah so during the first three months we
already saw a savings of 1.5 million
euros and this was just from optimizing
50 of the roots of just one of our
company's meaning Swiss so we expect the
overall savings from the project will be
very significant full of tanza also in
the more less non-digital word examples
which show the coexistence of cost
cutting sustainability increase and more
customer Comfort are easy to get look at
new aircraft save up to 30 percent Fuel
and thereby emissions they lower costs
proceed and increase comfort of customer
Comfort at the very same time so by
reducing emissions and also noise
pollution
call it as you want is win-win-win yes
across a number of variables win-win-win
I like that and Neil for your customers
a broader set of customers of course
given your customer base is data that
drives sustainability also clearly
driving other business outcomes yes
absolutely our customers tell us that's
exactly what's happening one of the
customers for example is Deutsche Bahn
Reggio the largest bus company in in
Germany with over 5000 buses connected
to the geotab platform by harnessing
Data Insights they make sure that the
vehicles are available for drivers on
time and ready to go they have a state
of charge evaluation reports on energy
consumption and they're using geotab
data for immediate feedback to their
drivers this feedback helps the drivers
correct Behavior like heavy braking some
of the outcomes reported include higher
driver satisfaction which is good 40
reduction in idling time and savings of
over 1400 tons of CO2 a substantial
reduction in fuel costs as well and
higher customer satisfaction so
absolutely by leveraging Data Insights
customers are benefiting from this
transformative change
so first of all thank you both for being
here and I think it's wonderful to see
the cases of sustainability in both your
organizations pairing beautifully with
you know operational efficiency cost
savings and creating wonderful customer
experiences please join me in thanking
both Stephanie and Neil for joining us
today thank you so much
that conversation leaves me truly
optimistic about what's to come
and it's all part of our overall goal to
help you make the sustainable Choice the
Easy Choice
for everyone
in life
in work
and in the cloud
so I'd like to close by thanking all of
our guests for illustrating what true
transformation looked like today in the
cloud and possibly for tomorrow
you are very valued customers bring the
possible to life and you inspire us each
and every day to deliver the technology
the tools and the solutions that drive
value Creation in the cloud
no matter what your circumstances are or
where you are on your journey
we will help you to better understand
your data
help you to apply technology so you can
lead in your industry
help you to ensure that your systems
your people your users are safe and
secure
we'll help you to create the best
workplace for your employees
and we will help you to drive
sustainability in your operations
so let me thank you once again for
placing your trust in Google Cloud
Google is investing for the future
and we are here to help
whatever comes next
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]